never before in the history of the world
have we had such an opportunity to
become knowledgeable with the Internet
there is an infinite amount of knowledge
that you can soak in you can become
super humanly intelligent yet for some
reason most of us squander this
opportunity
we watched PewDiePie h3h3 most people
when they make this type of video they
say funny cat videos
I don't watch funny cat videos I don't
know how many people actually do that
either way I'm not calling myself a
saint usually when I waste time it's on
the Internet but when used correctly the
Internet can be an incredible tool to
boost your knowledge increase your
intelligence and learn some very
practical real world skills so here are
five websites that have really helped
develop me into a smarter person with
more skills and just I'm more useful now
number one is YouTube believe it or not
right here right on this very website
YouTube is kind of a high-risk
high-reward platform for learning so
they put a rose dressing on the pizza
well there are millions of channels that
will waste a lot of your time there are
also an equal amount actually I don't
know if it's an equal amount but there
are a lot of channels that will teach
you real world skills in an entertaining
way you probably know this already if
you have any particular skill that you
want to learn that you're passionate
about there is no better place to find
tutorials for that thing than on YouTube
so if you subscribe to channels that
will help build you up and develop you
as a person like this one and
unsubscribe from all those channels that
will waste your time you will find that
you'll become a much better person in
the long run number two is Khan Academy
I used this website and back when it was
just the YouTube channel all throughout
high school it was a game changer you
want to learn chemistry physics math
history you name it economics computer
programming it's all there so if you're
looking for introductory to intermediate
knowledge on any academic subject you
can think of go to Khan Academy calm it
is an invaluable resource for diving
into the meat and potatoes of all these
different disciplines and teaching you
them from scratch number three is
duolingo now duolingo is both a website
and an app and it is the best tool I
have ever seen for learning a new
language which I encourage everyone to
do I learned more
one month of daily duolingo than I did
from one year of classroom Spanish
lessons that's how powerful this tool is
and the app is just incredible it's so
well polished so well fleshed out and it
sends you push notifications to remind
you every single day to work on your
skill so go learn a language and use
duolingo to do it number four is code
Academy sort of like Khan Academy but
for computer programming I'll be honest
I'm not into code too much
I have dabbled from the little bit that
I've used code Academy I have nothing
but good things to say about it and I
have some friends who are really into
code and every time that I mentioned
that I'm mildly interested in learning
it they always say the same thing every
single time they tell me to go to code
Academy it's completely free it's
interactive and it's one of those
real-world applicable skills I talked to
my last livestream about having a
marketable skill and when you have a
marketable skill people will want to pay
you money for it so if you don't have a
marketable talent and you have been
thinking about getting into code there's
no better time than right now as society
gets more digital everyone's gonna need
someone who knows code or at least
understands how it works in my fifth and
final recommendation for a website that
will make you smarter is believe it or
not read it now before you dislike the
video you got to hear me out reddit is a
very interesting site in that it is what
you make of it when you just make a
reddit account you have all these
different recommendations coming to you
on your homepage
and those are just the default
subreddits go ahead and unsubscribe from
every single one of those when you're
done that go ahead and subscribe to our
slash self-improvement our slash get
discipline there's a whole bunch of
other ones I'll link in the description
and these will provide you with valuable
communities of like-minded people who
are trying to improve themselves learn
new skills I don't think there's any
other website besides YouTube that
offers me so much consistent value on
sort of a community basis so subscribe
to subreddits that align with the skills
you're trying to learn and the habits
you're trying to develop and you'll find
that some of the advice on there is some
of the best advice you'll ever receive
in your life it can also be some of the
crappiest advice you've ever seen so
just definitely take everything on that
site with a grain of salt but this is
the Internet you should know that by now
so that's it the internet does not have
to be a place that sucks up all your
time and makes you a lazy
pathetic it can actually help you have a
better life you just have to use it in
the right way so by visiting the right
websites and unsubscribing from the
wrong ones
you can use the Internet to its fullest
potential and you can let it help you
reach yours if you like this video and
like videos like these hit that
subscribe button and that little bell
icon next to the subscribe button and if
you like these videos I produce and want
to help me make more videos and better
videos hit that link in the description
it'll take you to my patreon page and if
you become a $1 sponsor if I can get a
thousand people to become a $1 sponsor
on patreon I will quit my job and just
do better ideas full-time which means I
will dedicate a hundred percent of my
time to make videos just like this and
obviously way better because I'll have
nothing else to do except make these
videos so thank you very much for your
support I really appreciate it thanks
for watching and I'll catch you in the
next video